thank you very much for giving up a
little bit of your time on a friday
afternoon during what we New England
call Indian summer it's still mid-80s
beach weather and it's friday at two
thirty and you're in a conference room
with no windows so i'm going to try to
make this quick and efficient and
effective my hope over the next 20
minutes is that i can do three things
one is get you really excited about how
you can apply your craft or your
tradecraft your skills your experiences
your tools your methods your
organizations to help us make sense of
this new class or category of data
called IOT Internet of Things machine
data data from unattended devices I want
to get you excited about that because I
am I want to share with you why the
second thing I'd like to do is perhaps
accentuate that potential excitement or
interest by showing you what I think one
of the greatest opportunities is and
some of the challenges associated with
the opportunity show you ultimately in
the last and third part of the talk what
we need to do those of us that are in
the IOT community those of us that are
instrumenting the physical world
building devices building algorithms
models web services applications
creating new business models we need
your help and so I'm hoping that over
the next few minutes and get you excited
about those three things so lots of data
right we've been so busy on our screens
that we can hardly keep up so I pulled a
couple of exhibits from one of last
year's most popular talks the folks at
Georgetown giving this talk on was d
gelt and the quantity of transactions is
staggering I mean most of the time we're
talking about the data on a weekly or
monthly basis but we don't often talk
about the time associated with the
creation of those transactions or the
creation of that data so in link point I
want to make here is there is an
enormous volume of data that we humans
are creating with the time that we
invest in our screens it's called social
intelligence or socket but in the
physical world we've got billions of
transactions going on in parallel
water you can read some of these
statistics but some of them are a little
bit interesting when you look at the
quantity of the volume of water that's
required for example to produce a single
slice of bread it's 10 gallons how many
slices and a loaf how many loaves per
family per week per month so the first
thing I want to do is get you to think a
little bit differently about the
definition of the term transaction let's
not think about digital transactions so
much let's think about carbon
transactions and let's think about
carbon or natural resources let's think
about how much water we're consuming
every single day and let's think about
how little we actually have now this is
not a pitch I'm not one of those spotted
owl tongue kiss and pinko liberal
tree-hugging cats look I don't know how
much water we have but we don't have a
lot take a look at this golf ball
titleist is headquartered in my where my
office is now a new bedford that golf
balls the planet Earth in that little
dot over the I literally that dot the
ink the dye that's on the surface of
that golf ball that's how much fresh
potable water exists on a planet earth
relative to the golf ball being the
planet Earth in other words we don't
have that much now there are some
thinkers from one institution or another
that would tell you that by 2020 we will
have no fresh potable water problems I
think they're full of it and it's not
that I don't trust them which I don't
but it's that I'd rather be safe than
sorry so my teams are working on
instrumenting water trying to figure out
where the water is how much we have let
other people work on conservation I just
want to know where is it it's kind of
hard to do that now we've got brilliant
sources of geospatial intelligence much
of its been Declassified a lot of its
available commercially and we can sense
for surface moisture surface water if
you will but what if we want to go a
little deeper to where thirty percent of
the water is that's available to us on
the planet its groundwater
we're not doing so well we don't have
that much we don't have that much data I
just want you to think for one second
about the problem of water and the data
this is a live snapshot from the USGS
water website networked water wells I
took the snap shot last night 3000 wells
live about 2,700 network tour available
I just want you think about that for a
minute we think about the vast quantity
or volume of data that's available for I
don't know candy transactions through
Walt Disney World how much data they
have to understand how much candies
beings consumed by whom when how and why
and then you look at how much data we
don't have to figure out where water is
I think there's a gulf there's a gap I
think there's a huge opportunity and I
think the opportunity is becoming a cute
and it's becoming a cute because on the
left side here I'm just showing you the
latest from the climate conservation
corporation this shows the likelihood
that we will exhibit or evidence or
experienced a severe drought in the
southwest of the United States and as
the color gets darker red the likelihood
that will experience a severe drought in
that region goes up by 10 percentage
points so somewhere between 10 and 60
percent likelihood that there's going to
be a drought now on the other side of
the screen this is a map it's a it's a
highlight of the map you just saw
previously if you don't see any blue
dots we don't have any ground truth
intelligence on groundwater in other
words if you map these two targets
that's the four corners this is where
there's significant drought possibility
significant drought extant today and
that's where we have a drought of water
intelligence and water data we don't
know anything about where the water is
from a ground truth or an explicit
perspective it's inferential we have
experts and they're using project based
tools and methods they're using their
experience their subjectivity
their expertise they're bumping it up
against lots of inferential systems USGS
has some ground weather stations they
have some wells that are instrumented
but in many cases we're arriving at a
place where we're guessing and so what I
propose to you is this possibility that
we might not know nearly enough because
we can only build maps in many cases
with a resolution of a hundred square
miles now how many of you own property
that's 100 square miles are greater not
many which means we don't know how much
water you have we don't know how much
water you might have because we don't
have data that could give us a map with
the resolution that could provide us
with the kind of intelligence to make
the kind of policy decisions or
investment decisions that we really need
to start to make 100 square miles so
what happens what happens is we're at
this moment right now where we wish we
had these databases now we've got
databases in IT and in the business
world and operations technology
real-time embedded I've got all kinds of
social intelligence and open source
intelligence and geospatial intelligence
we've got all kinds and sources of data
but the one we don't really have is this
thing we call device intelligence on the
physical world the IOT data we don't
have it so we start to try and plan for
build for invest in a better future and
we're in this present moment right now
and we're making decisions we don't have
what we call this fulcrum data the most
important data about water resources and
accessibility and so we end up with all
kinds of uneven decision support for the
challenges that are coming in other
words it's like we're back 10 or 12
years driving a tight suspension sports
car on a pothole filled road and we
don't have over sampling on the CD
player in other words it's skipping a
lot in other words we've got a lot of
gaps in our water intelligence but what
if you take it one step further and say
okay so we don't have enough data we
don't have the resolution and maybe the
policy is not as
tight as it could be but what's the net
effect look the net effect is poor asset
optimization we're leaving money on the
table we're leaving health on the table
we're leaving well-being on the table
we're leaving in many cases elements of
our futures for ourselves and our kids
and our grandkids on the table and
furthermore to take it to the nth degree
we're just opening ourselves up to
conflict whether it's legal or physical
whether its intellectual or kinetic the
fact is if people don't have water
they're going to fight and whether it's
in a courtroom or in a street fists
stick knife gun or tort if we don't
figure out water we're going to be
fighting about it so we ask the question
what if we could effectively deploy a
whole bunch of sensors to get some of
those gaps filled I can attest that we
have every single technology required to
do that today from low cost low power
high reliability broad availability
sensors from materials to power sources
we've got the algorithms and the models
being built and the web service
architecture is basically available to
us everything's there and people are
starting to put it together imagine
deploying widely sensors that could tell
us where the water is level sensing and
then maybe in some near-term future what
the quality that water is or might be
what then this is a map of an area of
California that was instrumented with
just that type of sensor and all it did
was increase the resolution of accurate
water table forecasting a modeling 800
times this model is a hundred square
meter model got 100 square mile model
when you put sensors in the ground we
can create ground truth we can compress
the inference moments and the
extrapolation requirements we can get
real live readings of water levels in
individual water wells on individual
properties it gives us that ground truth
to stitch together with that geospatial
intelligence that weather data and that
other inferential and contextual they
now you might say well who needs that
resolution well depends on who you ask
and this is where I think we need your
help because when we talk about the
Internet of Things most often we're
talking about brands connecting products
so that they can have persistent
marketing surveillance on customers they
can know everything that customers doing
and anticipate every need and extract
more time and extract more revenue and
extract more profit from that customer
on the other side we talk about
customers getting some benefit it's
usually convenience sometimes it's
entertainment and sometimes it's
actually real value now I know I sound
cynical and I am a little bit because
most of the machine to machine and IOT
that's been deployed today hasn't really
been delivering much on the promises of
return on investment compliance cost
reduction revenue enhancement it all
kinds of better experiences for either
individual enterprise or institutional
customers they've been fallen short and
I think one of the reasons why either
been falling short is because they've
been bound by buyer-seller relationship
thinking and so I'd want you to look at
this it's a really simple model it's
more like a soccer ball but we'll go two
dimensions what I love about what I've
heard over the past two days is that so
many people working on so many different
versions of the tools that we need in
the Internet of Things to create the
maximum value this model says start with
the asset ground water or a water well
and map all of the potential
stakeholders that might have a shared or
common or unique interest in knowing if
there's water in that location because
it's not just the homeowner or it's not
just the municipality and it's certainly
not just the company that builds the
sensor to build the database to go and
hyper concentrate all this water
intelligence and try and go and be the
Google of water intelligence or the
Facebook of water intelligence or some
other dominant business model for water
intelligence we're talking about
something that's far more important but
this kind of complex subscriber
enablement model I've really only seen
deployed well and classified and secured
national intelligence community
deployments you say this another way
this isn't like Netflix where someone
subscribes and they rent or you know
it's just not like that it isn't a big
monolithic bit pipe and it's not even
sort of one-way or even two-way party to
party this is the kind of model that has
to say well who's going to care about
what data and we have to start answering
those questions even before we start
deploying because to answer these
questions is to understand how we might
architect our systems but more than that
what we might define in terms of our
policies see I don't think this is a
technical challenge I think this is a
policy challenge when I say policy i
don't mean government I don't need
legislation or regulation I mean how we
think about that data now if you just
think about the homeowner there are at
least three ways the homeowner gets
massive value from understanding if you
live in a home that's fed by a water
well the first thing you get is a little
bit of peace of mind about quality of
service you know you've got water you'll
know when the level goes down so you
won't have brown water events you won't
have pump burnout events or you'll have
fewer you'll save real money have real
high quality of service the second thing
you'll have is imagine if you live in a
property that's in a water stressed area
you've now just got verification
attestation that you have water in this
property so now your property becomes
more valuable because you've got
verification that it's got clean potable
regular supply of water and here's the
third one what if we got to place in
time where we could create a market for
groundwater that homeowner whose
instrumented his or her well and is
pretty good practicing conservation
methodologies and techniques might be
able to quote unquote sell rights to
their excess water capacity but that's
just the homeowner look at all these
other stakeholders that would have
something to gain in compliance or cost
reduction or safety or revenue
enhancement but getting access to some
part of that data and that's just the
residential what if we went into any of
these other spaces where massive water
consumption takes place right now
there's massive debate going on in
agriculture can read now an article from
AG review and the folks at Farm Bureau
saying farmers
producers go ahead instrument everything
you can because it will help you with
yield and productivity and profitability
and conservation it'll be good but make
sure you understand who owns the data
who gets control and access and who else
is going to get to essentially exploit
data about your equipment your machinery
your operations your environment what
we're talking about a new instrument
things like water is like the nth degree
of the shared economy my water well
doesn't just pull from a small tube
that's under my property we're sharing
water on the planet it's a shared
resource don't talk about the shared
economy this is one that could be a
blockbuster for us to redefine how we
deal with each other how we deal with
these assets and also how we deal with
that data because it won't just be value
in water that'll be value in water data
but give you one example of the positive
unintended consequences of thinking this
way there's a European water pump
company that deployed an m2 MRI OT
solution on all of their water pumps you
know in a couple of different regions of
Africa western Africa and the horn and
they put these devices on the pump so
that they could know remotely so the
pumps had a little cellular modem on I'm
A to G modem went to a tower over the
top back to the cloud into some facility
in Western Europe and somebody like me
could sit in a network operating center
and see every one of the pumps and the
continent of Africa that was owned or
controlled by this OEM could see if it
was on could see if it was running could
see it what RPM could do things like
vibration and concatenation and
temperature could get all kinds of
health and wellness on the pump but what
it didn't really do her couldn't do
necessarily was give us that kind of
groundwater knowledge now of water came
out of the pump yippee skippy we have
water but no idea how much is left put
that aside what they did was they
thought about this multi-stakeholder
model they thought about well drillers
and well servicing companies and how
they could have route optimization
enabled by knowing what the status of
the pump was so instead of putting boots
in a truck and a truck and every pump
you only planned your routes when you
saw that you had read the pump problem
or yellow a pump problem emerging they
also spent a hell of a
time thinking about what happens in
nation-states in regions and prefecture
xand districts among families and tribes
and clans and political parties and
different nations on that continent or
any continent when there's a water
problem the water flows then people will
vote if there's no water people aren't
voting they're not going to work they're
not going to school but here's the
kicker love this case they thought about
how it could impact the lives of people
so this company said let's take some of
that data scrape it create a service and
we'll send alerts to people who have
feature phones in these areas of
operation where we light the pumps up
and just like people united states can
figure out where the nearest starbucks
is and pre-order their latte and do all
that kind of cool stuff what this
company did was said we're going to
create a free service an SMS service so
that people in these areas of operation
can know where the pumps are running and
where they're pushing water and even
further where there isn't a long line to
wait to get water now you could say
that's charity I say that's freaking
brilliant because they took time to
water for the average family in the area
of operation down from eight hours a day
to three and a half so the average
family living at or near subsistence got
four and a half hours a day back in
their adult population to heal wounds to
raise children to learn language to
learn skills to build businesses to feed
to clothe to go from subsistence to
something more meaningful now they
started with a simple route optimization
play asset optimization play but i think
what ends up happening is as you give
more people more time to do more
valuable things with their lives all the
other good stuff happens but this stuff
doesn't happen unless we ask the
questions early on and often how does
this happen how are we going to get to
do this well so we have the simple model
and we get in trouble all the time when
we talked to classic venture capitalists
who are about scale rapidly go first
thing is you're going to spend more time
in the first 30 days talking about this
complex subscription model mapping all
these stakeholders in all these
interests you're going to slow yourself
down you're going to introduce new
privacy new security more complexity you
will be slowed down in the first 30 days
and then over the next 30 months are
going to have to make sure you have op X
to support the continued investment in
the policies and the technologies tools
methods partnerships relationships
industry infrastructure to make sure
that it sticks but over the next 30
years because some pumps run for 30
years you'll reap the benefits with your
partners alright cute philosophical how
do you really do it there's a multi-step
process that we've deployed with a
number of industry groups a number of
fortune 50s and a number of startups and
the process is all about what you've
been talking about over the past two
days definitions and standards not
necessarily technical but when we say
pressure what do we mean and one of the
things that holds up the deployment of
IOT is this all the different vendors of
all the different products have
different ways of defining something
like hours of service some do it with
minutes some do it in hours let's say
we're all going to say we're all going
to do in hours how many places to the
left of the decimal point how many
places to the right we're going to label
it hours the word or the abbreviation
we're going to go abbreviation fine is
it hrs or HR hrs great capital H
lowercase period no period that kind of
Arcana most OEMs most deployers most
field service organizations most
integrators say that that is just the
the dumbest stuff they've conceived of
in their entire careers but it's the
kind of stuff that slows it down I share
this with you because we've deployed it
we're deploying it today it works one
last point we're going to produce more
data from unattended devices over the
next five years ten years then we've
seen in the trailing you pick it I don't
care it's irrelevant because we have
almost zero penetration of the vast
majority of large and landscape scale
assets remote in mobile assets and
living assets on the planet Earth set
another way there are groups putting
sensors and trees because they're
growing heritage hardwood and it's at a
huge risk of shrinkage so they put a
sense or acoustic or vibration point is
anything that's worth caring about is
worth knowing about anything worth
knowing about is worth instrumenting
there's going to be a ton of this stuff
coming down the pike we need your help
to get it done I hope I've excited you
about what it is what the opportunities
and challenges are and how folks in this
space could participate